[Music]
walk it down any supermarket aisle and
you'll find lots of fruits with health
claims on it low-fat low-sugar
gluten-free zero calories vegan and more
well they're supposed to be healthier
for you but are they really don't be
fooled these health claims are mainly a
marketers way to make a spend more and
feel good thinking that you're consuming
something that's gonna help with your
waistline the truth is a lot majority of
so-called diet foods are actually filled
with sodium trans fat artificial sugars
and more ingredients which we can barely
pronounce if eaten regularly these foods
may even sabotage your weight loss goals
here are my top seven diet foods that
are going to make you fat
number one diet soda drinks but it's
zero calories isn't weight loss all
about calorie in and calorie out
well yes and no yes diet soda drinks may
contain zero calories but do you know
that drinking it on a regular basis can
stimulate your appetite and increase
cravings for more sugary foods that's
because most diet soda drinks contain
artificial sweeteners such as aspartame
and aspartame ranks 200 times sweeter
than your white table sugar and what it
does is that instead of satisfying your
sugar cravings
it actually prolongs your sugar cravings
so you're still being deprived from
having real sugar as a result you're
more likely to consume other sugary
foods and drinks which can eventually
lead to weight gain a study found that
diet soda drinkers had a 70% greater
increase in waist circumference compared
to non drinkers here's a tip replace
your daily diet fizzy drinks with
sparkling water or make your own
naturally infused fruity sparkling water
protein bars gosh I have no time for a
proper meal but look I'm having a
protein bar
it contains 20 grams of protein and
me one gram of sugar so I'm still
hitting my protein intake can I just say
that that's absolute rubbish we see
those gym addicts often consuming
protein bars as their pre-workout or
even on-the-go snack for the busy people
but are they really healthy yes it may
be low in sugar but again sugar is often
replaced by artificial sweeteners and
when you look at the calorie count it's
often just as high as a regular
chocolate bar which is typically between
180 to 220 calories plus you might not
even feel like you've eaten a meal just
by eating one bar so chances are you
might even reach for another bar and
that's a whopping 400 calories you might
as well just eat a hamburger at least
you'll feel satisfied
remember this nothing from a packet can
ever replace real nutritious food here's
a tip consume real foods such as eggs
whole fruits nuts and seeds oats and
vegetables and do check out my video on
healthy snack ideas next low-fat or
fat-free foods low-fat milk fat free
yogurt zero fat dressing you name it
there's always a low-fat or fat-free
alternative for everything fat is not
your enemy there are healthy fats which
we should be consuming your body needs
fat to burn fat and also to help with
absorption of some essential nutrients
and vitamins such as vitamin A D and K
and antioxidants from foods such as
leafy greens carrots and tomatoes
remember this love that does not mean
low calories or sugar free when food
manufacturers remove the fat from foods
they will inevitably remove some of the
flavors now in order to make up for the
lack of flavors they will have to add a
whole bunch of other stuff such as sugar
high fructose corn syrup or other kind
of artificial sweeteners consume full
fat yogurt and avoid low-fat yogurt the
healthiest salad dressings are made
without sugar and contain
natural health effects such as olive oil
which provide benefits for heart health
it is so much better to make your own
dressing using olive oil vinegar and
some spices it is that simple
next gluten-free processed foods I will
never forget a conversation I had with a
girlfriend who was on a diet let's have
dinner
oh I've eaten what did you eat gluten
free potato chips my mind went if you
understand where gluten comes from and
what food contains gluten you would
already know that potato has no gluten
and any potato chips you buy will be
gluten free like I said it's just
another marketing gimmick to put the
gluten free label onto a product to make
us think that it is healthy gluten-free
cookies muffins or cakes look processed
foods where the gluten free or not are
not good for us and can cause weight
gain it doesn't give you the allowance
to consume more and it is not a good
option for weight loss if you read the
ingredients list it will still contain
high sugar unhealthy fat and calories
sometimes a gluten free products may
even contain more sugar fats and
calories
just to make up for the lack of taste if
you want to reduce your gluten free
intake opt for naturally gluten-free
foods like meats nuts fruits and
vegetables instead of processed
gluten-free foods the next healthy food
granola
if you're eating granola for breakfast
you've got to stop it is constantly
being advertised as a healthier choice
but the reality is it is not it should
be treated as dessert because the sugar
content is as high as desert hence
should only be eaten occasionally yes
granola contains a lot of fiber and iron
from oats while the nuts and seeds add
heart-healthy unsaturated fats however
they are very high in calories because
they contain additional oil and sugar
which we just don't need
a quarter cup of granola typically
contains more than 200 calories and
about 20 grams of sugar that's just like
having chocolate éclairs and trust me
that one small portion will not fill you
up so chances are you will be consuming
double or triple that portion so
breakfast can rack up to 700 calories
and 60 grams of sugar and you're
wondering why am I not losing weight I'm
consuming granola for breakfast here's a
tip opt for muesli instead or even
better make your own where you're able
to add more rolled oats and have the
nuts seeds and dried fruits in small
quantities plus it is so much cheaper
vitamin sports or energy drinks these
are often sneaky and wasted calories
that we just don't need most of the time
sports drinks were designed with high
performance athletes in mind these
drinks contain electrolytes aka salt and
carbs aka sugar to keep them hydrated
and replenish lost minerals such as
sodium potassium and chloride especially
after a prolonged intense exercise now
hitting the treadmill for half an hour
and then lifting some weights does not
require nearly the same amount of carbs
or electrolytes we can get these
nutrients from the food we normally eat
this vitamin spot or energy drinks
contain just as much and sometimes even
more sugar than a can of soda if you
want vitamin carry through supplements
not some sort of a vitamin drink that
contains a whopping 33 grams of sugar if
you really feel that you need that extra
energy boost for your workout then fill
your body with enough healthy carbs and
protein before and after such as bananas
yogurt oatmeal eggs or go for
supplements such as BCAA or a protein
shake these are much healthier options
compared to a sugary drink and just stay
high
on plain refreshing water and finally
100% real vegetable chips made from 100%
real vegetable well potato chips is also
made from 100% real potato if you think
that you can feel less guilty enjoying
eating kale bits of zucchini don't also
forget about the vegetable oil salt and
potato starch added into the mixture to
produce real 100% veggie chips here's a
comparison one ounce serving of
vegetable chips contains 134 calories
and 6 point 6 grams of fat of which 0.5
grams is saturated and 1 ounce serving
of potato chips contains 154 calories
and ten point three grams of fat of
which 1.1 grams are saturated yes it is
a slightly better option but it's not
going to do your diet wonders and you
should not feel good or think that
you're going to get your five a day
because chances are most of the
nutrients and vitamins are gone the best
option is of course stick to fresh stuff
enjoy fresh veggie with hummus or bake
your own veggie chips to cut back on the
fat and sodium the bottom line is
nothing beats real natural food consume
more natural food and reduce our
processed food and remember do not be
fooled by the health claims always flip
the products and read the ingredients
list if there are too many ingredients
which you can't even pronounce or if
sugar is listed as the first two
ingredients well it is best to avoid it
I believe in balance and moderation of
course you can still enjoy these foods
in moderation but not on a daily basis
what are the healthy foods are causing
you to gain weight or ruin your diet let
me know in the comments below be sure to
give this video a thumbs up share this
video and subscribe to my youtube
channel do check out more fitness tips
healthy recipes and workout videos all
the best